I'm shallow first slow down I'm here  working on the launch trailer for Mortal  Kombat X this song is really really  strong and I was excited because I love  the game our label didn't want a song on  her album called suicide so we chopped  suicide an app and got to chop silly  this is more like making that song even  crazier wake up I think it has some song  it's actually a reality song it could be  editing it was so fun just because  there's so much to fuse  we're se caen he scrapes until forsaken  okay  I felt more like I was editing a movie I  kind of forgot that it was a video game  during the Edit fans of the game really  love this it's top notch  I hope to do more you know in the future  maybe Mortal Kombat X X like xxx as a  different movie sorry